this is an article that looked at the
differences between men and women's
views on abortion so oh i think i
suspected i shared it the other day
polls consistently show that women are
more likely than men to support a
reduction in the abortion limit in 2011
a yougov poll 28 of men supported a
reduction 46 percent of women did 2012
24 of men and 49 percent of women so
that's gone down for men and up for
women uh in an angus read poll uh 35
percent of men's 59 of women and then 45
of men and 59 women this raises some
pretty big implications the most obvious
being that if it were left to women to
vote on the issue with men out of the
picture there's a good chance that the
result would be in favor of restricting
abortion on the flip side if only men
voted they'd almost certainly vote in
favor of women's reproductive rights
let's break that down because that's
really interesting
why
is that why is that
they put forward a bunch of different
potential explanations yeah um
one of them being that women who go
through childbirth
are part of that group and if you've had
a child if you have given birth to a
child right your support for abortion
seems to go down quite yeah sort of
rightly so you it's magical you realize
that this is the sort of thing you want
your friends to enjoy and experience and
build families
yep that makes sense
and then
i i just think of like whenever i think
of more men
if if it was possible i mean this is
what i would think more men want
abortion because it's just a bunch of
bros who don't want kids
you know it's it but obviously it's not
the case wait no it is the case right so
men men are vying for more abortion or
more men are vying for abortion rights
that's correct right yes yes
because we're just a bunch of bros they
don't that's it so what they're saying
is that this is this is this still got
linked around somehow this got linked
around to the misogynistic patriarchal
substructure substrate construct that
overarches everything and said well look
what's happening here this is obvious
it's obvious that men are just trying to
control women's bodies still they're
permitting them to have their body their
choice but this just permits men to
spray it around as much as they want and
not really time their withdrawal method
too well
yep wait so
that
wait i'm sorry so the assumption that
more men would vote for abortion leads
you to that or is it the other way
around so
men want to have a
reduction
in the number of restrictions on
abortion which means that more people
will be able to get them which would
permit them to have more sex more
liberally with less protection and less
good timing on their withdrawals
it's one of those things where it's like
um
there there is no opposing the argument
because you use the opposition of the
argument against them there's a really
good one um
the i forget who it was it was one of
the gracies which the gracies are the
founding
family of brazilian jiu jitsu
and there was this lore of
i think it might have been helio gracie
but
i'm not entirely sure but he went to
fight uh kimura
which now is a common uh
it's a common like attack that we use in
jiu jitsu and kimura is a japanese
i think like judoka so judo whatever and
um
they made this huge thing that um
you know it was a it was a massive fight
and helio was like 50 pounds underweight
and
you know gave kimura the greatest fight
of his life
and kimura ended up beating him
um
fast forward to
you know later
i think it was hicks and gracie
um and did you have him on your show by
the way no i decided against it
okay
uh we can talk about that in a bit but
uh you read his book i think right yeah
okay so basically hicks and gracie i
think was beat by someone
um and what the gracie said was he used
good like gracie style jiu jitsu to beat
us
i'm not sure if they said that against
the about the kimura fight
but that's kind of the idea is like
even if you beat me
you know it's because of the ideas that
i had
that you beat me yeah right which is the
same thing here what's happening here is
that you have you have an ideology
and then you try and wrap you trap rap
reality around that ideology so it's
unfalsifiable and no matter what
direction you covered it from
it's still
yeah i mean that's always fun isn't it
you're in austin texas right now i mean
are there people on this very [ __ ]
like protesting this is anyone talking
about it in the gym
uh it's it's a very liberal city
so so people might not understand that
they must be pissed
yeah i think um you know just go on
instagram and you can find a lot more
pissed people about this
you know across the country
it's very interesting that at the in the
same week that greg
greg abbott the governor says
that uh abortions will not be allowed
um after six weeks
of pregnancy
that conceal and carry does not require
uh a license anymore what's that mean
so you can conceal a weapon or a firearm
uh without having a license or without
having to get gain a license do you need
a special kind of license to do a
concealed carry because presumably you
need one for the gun but then you need
extra training so i don't want to carry
it
that's usually the case right so you
usually go to like a weekend
training course you have to i think you
have to take some tests and then you
have to file and then you can get your
uh conceal and carry
and i believe that now it's almost
completely
gone that that concealing carry
you know bylaw where you have to take a
course people walking around so we
like the same week that we we have now
have like the most lenient gun control
laws we have the most extreme abortion
laws
so people think that texas is [ __ ]
crazy yeah okay
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace
you